et
au volant de sa voiture gérard attend au
feu rouge derrière un autre véhicule
le feu passe au vert et deux voitures
des mains soudain un cycliste brûle son
feu rouge et surgit devant la première
voiture au docteur ferrari juste
derrière frat la première voiture selon
son assureur gérard est responsable de
l'accident et devra payer la franchise
de 500 $ prévue à son contrat
l'assureur a t'il le dernier mot en la
matière non les assureurs s'appuie sur
la convention d'indemnisation directe
cette convention sert à déterminer quel
automobiliste est responsable de
l'accident et elle ne tient jamais
compte des circonstances elle dit qu'un
conducteur du crap le véhicule qui est
en lui et responsable de l'accident à
100% mais ce que l'assureur ne dit pas à
gérard c'est que cette convention ne lis
que des assureurs entrepris par les
automobilistes
gérard pourrait contester la décision de
son assureur et même réclamé le
remboursement de sa franchise aux
petites créances
les automobilistes dont déjà fait et ont
réussi à se faire déclarer nos
responsables d'un accident par le
tribunal
le fin mot de l'histoire ce n'est pas la
convention d'indemnisation directe des
assureurs qui a le dernier mot
c'est le juge qui se basent lui sur les
circonstances de l'accident